today I'm going to give you a quick book
contest update as well as some exciting
announcements what's up believe nation
welcome to another edition of Evans book
I'm excited to dig into the contest I've
had it for the past two weeks on the
channel to have a contest to give away
10 signed copies of my book for people
who create some art around it I'm
actually filming this on Wednesday my
normal filming day which is december
twenty eighth and so i can't announce
the contest winners yet because i want
to give a little bit more time if you
guys who create some art so I know this
is coming up to you guys live already on
january second but i'm filming at
december twenty eighth so next week I'm
going to be picking the winners good
luck to you all I'm excited to see what
you have come up with while I've got you
here though I wanted to also share a
couple of excited announcements that I
have for the book series and see what
you guys think you see how I feel about
them but here are some of the ideas that
I'm playing with so first off is going
to be the book club hangouts doing a
weekly series for seven weeks for each
chapter of the book to help people along
the way you guys can join in on the live
hangout ask me questions chat with other
believe nation members who are reading
the book because I really again want to
make sure that people are reading the
book they understand that they're
getting the value from it and sort of
thing I can do to help make sure that
you are getting value from it you're
taking action on it you're actually
reading the book and applying it to your
life or business I want to make sure
that gets done that series may continue
may just be a one-off seven weeks that's
it it may be an ongoing thing or repeat
it again and maybe have some special
guests come in we were the in the book
or people who are going through the
process of reading the book and helping
them live I don't know playing with some
ideas I'm open to some feedback but
that's going to probably start right
after we finish the contest some of the
ideas that I had we're to do some book
reaction videos a number of you have
sent in the videos of you unboxing your
book or sending the thank you message
and I thought about smashing all those
up into one video because they made me
feel so good and happy when I saw them
and to give some love and exposure for
you guys for making the videos I might
do that too also pro tip if you guys
making reaction videos send it to me so
they can be part of that mash up and get
some exposure in the channel 2 i'm
thinking about making a what i learned
as a message to myself for going through
this again because it's been some things
I think I did really well in launching
this book and some things that could
definitely be improved next time around
that I need to remember if in case I do
it again I need to watch this video back
it's a message from evan from past evan
to you know the next Evon when i'm going
to this again to do these things because
it could have been so easy you could
have saved a lot of headache so i'm
already planning that so it's another
idea and then the last one I had at
least on my list of current ideas is to
do a series of from rookie two
best-selling author and every week kind
of comparing how my book is doing
against a successful author if you look
at Tim Ferriss or Brian Tracy you're
Tony Robbins or any anybody who's in the
kind of business or personal development
taking my book and matching it up and
seeing how well we're doing against that
author and then also taking a bit of
advice from that author what has brian
tracy or Tony Robbins said about book
promotion and then me trying to go out
and do it and then reporting back the
next week it's something that's on my
mind sotano worked it with that together
but i'm kind of curious to see and i
like that idea from rookie two
best-selling authors so those are the
things that are my plate some of the
things that I'm planning in 2017 for the
continuation of this book series good
luck to all the contest entries next
week will be the grand reveal of who
wins so I'm excited for that and I'm
curious to hear your thoughts about
future video ideas what do you think
what the list I threw out there like it
leave it do you have other thoughts
you'd like to see me talk about in this
book series leave it down the comments
below thank you guys so much every week
for watching I really appreciate it
thank you for everybody who's picked up
a copy of the book and enjoyed it mad
love mad love mad love so much I believe
in you I hope you guys continue to
believe in yourself and whatever your
one where it is much love I'll see you
soon